in Breuberg im Hessen bietet der
gemeinnützige Verein mäusebandel
dringend benötigte Betreuung für
Kleinkinder an weil der städtische
Neubauer aber nicht fertig wird haben 25
Kinder im benachbarten Mömlingen
Unterschlupf gefunden da Mömlingen aber
knapp hinter der Landesgrenze in Bayern
liegt weigert sich Hessen etwa 116.000 €
Fördermittel für seine Kinder zu zahlen
Händeringen werden überall Plätze
gesucht wir haben eine Möglichkeit
geschaffen und werden jetzt im Prinzip
dafür bestraft dass wir die Möglichkeit
geschaffen haben nur weil es an der
Landesgrenze scheidet unmenschlich finde
ich es einfach unmenschlich ich finde
wir sind dringend auf diese Kitaplätze
angewiesen Ende 2022 ist klar der Verein
mäusebande braucht für zwei Gruppen ein
Ausweichquartier die bislang genutzten
Container sind marode und der städtische
Kita Neubau wird nicht rechtzeitig
fertig
unbürokratische Nachbarschaftshilfe
kommt aus Mömlingen hier finden 25
Kleinkinder samt Betreuerinnen
übergangsweise ein Obdach sportigen Kita
Mömlingen liegt kurz hinter der
Landesgrenze in Bayern also werden
hessische Kinder von hessischen
Fachkräften in Bayern betreut so geht's
nicht meint das Land Hessen wenn der
Einrichtung Fehler eine hessische
Betriebserlaubnis die bereits mündlich
zugesagten Fördergelder werden nicht
ausgezahlt für den Verein ein Schock wir
kämpfen seitdem um die Gelder die uns ja
eigentlich zustehen weil es sind
hessische Kinder und die werden hier
betreut in Bayern und wir kämpfen nur
noch darum das heißt immer Land will
irgendwie irgendwas tun für Kinder und
Familien und die Bildung und es passiert
eben nicht das Hessische
Sozialministerium teilt uns mit man habe
den Fall in Sachen Fördermittel geprüft
aber die Betreuung der Kinder findet
außerhalb unseres Hoheitsgebiets statt
daher lag die Entscheidung nicht bei uns
sondern in Bayern
das bayerische Sozialministerium
wiederum verweist darauf dass es sich um
hessische kinderhandele eine Förderung
können es nur geben wenn es sich um
kinderhandelt die im Gemeindegebiet
ihren gewöhnlichen Aufenthalt genommen
haben ein föderales Fördermittel Fiasko
denn die Kinder fallen durch alle Raster
ich finde es unfassbar dass die Behörden
da es allen Beteiligten so schwierig
machen den den Betreuerinnen den Eltern
und vor allen Dingen den Kindern die
sind wahrscheinlich selber nicht
betroffen denke ich und sitzen
vielleicht am Bürotisch rum und
entscheiden das dort für den Verein
geht's mittlerweile um die Existenz wenn
er dicht machen muss fallen nicht nur 25
Betreuungsplätze in Mömlingen weg
sondern alle 70 das kann ernsthaft
niemand wollen